[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля
Литячі]
Я належу до тих, кого потім називали дисидентами.
Вчитель музики за фахом.
Мав кілька ансамблів добрих.
Ми вже співали не те,
що партії при комсомолах.
Очевидно, що я то все ігнорував.
Вирішив сам собі писати те, що я хотів.
[Садиба-музей Богдана Горбаля
«Галерея Богдана»]
Читав той самвидав.
За вироком я мав відсидіти 23 роки.
Я був, щоправда, тільки 16 років.
Я був в тому таборі, з якого
не вийшов: Стус, Литвин, Тихий...
Я почув, що у 1976 році у Києві
створили Гельсінську групу.
[Микола Горбаль
Засновник музею «Галерея Богдана»]
Я зрозумів, що моє місце серед тих хлопців.
І коли я в 1977 році звільнився, то я приїхав.
Так я мав другий термін, так я мав потім...
Потім з другого мене загалом не випустили.
За день до звільнення мене арештували.
Але це окрема тема.
А тепер про Богдана, мого брата.
Зараз я знаю, що це називається «синдром Дауна».
Ця дитина щось собі малювала,
а мама його малюнками підпалювала піч.
Я страшенно шкодую.
Бо коли мене привезли у таборі в Мордовію,
Я вжахнувся!
Я побачив тих людей, ті колони...
Тих таких стрижених, бо всі там пострижені,
в сіреньких костюмах,
з собаками, з тими автоматами, той конвой...
Я думаю: «Господи Боже, та я ж це все бачив!
Богдан це все малював».
І думаю: «Господи, якась містика!»
Я написав мамі, кажу:
«Мамо, не викидайте ті малюнки!»
Ну але хто цих...
Кого ти переконаєш.
У 1993 році, коли я собі придбав
помешкання в Києві,
я Богдана забрав з мамою до Києва.
Тут все стало пусткою.
З 2006 року я кожне літо їздив сюди.
І тут викорчовував, приводив до порядку.
Далі добудовував там
два поверхи для галереї.
Потім усе це перекрив.
І так виникла ця галерея.
Богдан в Києві очевидно, що малював.
Я вже то не викидав.
Мені страшенно шкода, що тих
малюнків не збереглось,
які в мене залишилися в пам'яті.
Це я умовно назвав «Прийми нас, Господе».
Натовп людей десь біля храму.
Але потім я вирішив не давати ніякі назви.
Бо я ставлю глядача перед фактом,
що його так треба сприймати.
Це щось духовне, а це раціо.
Це щось таке, трохи інші речі.
Тобто що це таке я не знаю.
Це якась складна техніка.
І як це розуміти, мені важко сказати.
Ніхто навіть олівця його не вчив.
Якби може вчив, то, можливо,
були б якісь інші малюнки.
Мене часом питають: «Чому не фарбою?»,
бо це кольоровий олівець.
Та бо ніхто йому не давав.
Я знав, що я приїжджав з Борщова на мотоциклі,
привозив йому альбоми,
формат такий А4 і кольорові олівці.
Тому він так і малював кольоровими олівцями.
Я часом дивився, як він починає малювати.
Художники захоплено кажуть: «Дивіться, яка композиція! Тут все правильно».
Наш Богдан не знає, що таке композиція.
Він часом починає з куточка малювати і...
Бо, здається, мав би з центру.
Якось планувати свою роботу,
картину, як художник.
У мене таке враження, що він наперед,
так би мовити, знав той сюжет,
який має бути.
І йому байдуже звідки його починати малювати
Така от дивна техніка. Це – кулькова ручка.
Такий мурашник.
Такий натовп людей.
Благодійний фонд так і називається –
«Галерея Богдана».
Цей фонд започаткований,
щоб при можливості мати кошти
і допомагати людям з синдромом Дауна
реалізувати себе, вийти в світ.
Це Богданові малюнки. Також.
Оскільки це була стайня тут наша,
то я тут козликів цих прилаштував.
Тут також щось таке з худобою,
Богдановий малюнок.
Його любили тваринки.
Я приходжу, він тут малює,
а кури по ньому можуть скакати.
а я приходжу — кури втікають від мене,
Хоч я їх ніколи не лякав.
Ну, якась, видно, енергія інша в людини.
Там сестра.
Сестра моя, Марія каже:
«Нам здається, що Богдана краще розуміли рослини і тварини, аніж ми, люди».
Я почуваюся винним
перед цим чоловіком.
Бо я часом соромився його, бо нормальний...
Часом забороняв йому йти між людей.
Не треба було цього робити.
Але я віддав цю шану цьому
чоловікові перед Богом.
Я зробив все.
А там далі буде видно.
Питають мене, чи тут хтось ходить.
Та ніхто тут не ходить.
Чи багато тут села було?
Та не було!
Я мусив це зробити.
І я це зробив.
Прийде час, коли то буде цікаво людям.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Андрій Рогозін]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Субтитрувальниця
Марія Кравченко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]